this is a rare case where the attacks by
Hamas I think are completely and utterly
indefensible what does this mean Visa
the United States um and this is a place
where I think the libertarian principle
of
non-intervention is you know is strong
and should be maintained um Israel is
one country you know certainly an ally
to the US that can defend itself and has
shown its ability to do it without going
into questions about ongoing Aid to you
know Israel Egypt Saudi Arabia other
people the area other countries in the
area um this is something that the US
can you know uh can show support moral
support and humanitarian Aid and things
like that but we don't need to be
involved militarily and in fact I think
the minute we do that that is one of the
things that will tip things into a
larger conflict uh that we would be
smart to avoid